[Music]
hey what's up everybody I recently came
across an interview that Chris Pratt did
with Radio Times comm the interview is
about Jurassic world but during the
interview he is asked what he thinks
about all of the fans blaming star-lord
for Thanos to snap happening turns out
Chris Pratt actually has an opinion on
the matter and was not hesitant and
giving it I really enjoy what he says an
interview because Chris Pratt is
star-lord he is the mindset of star-lord
in the MCU so when he talks we are sort
of getting star Lords perspective on
when he started to punch Stannis
multiple times in the face ultimately
making it to where the Avengers did not
get the Infinity Gauntlet from Thanos
when he first starts talking about
everything he gets you in the mindset of
star-lord and he says that star-lord has
just been through so much tragedy and
it's true if you think back in the first
two guardians of the galaxy movies
everything that he's been through has
been tragic for the most part the guy
watched his mother die he watched as his
father figure died in his arms he was
forced to kill his own biological father
and now has suffered the loss of the
love of his life and so on taking these
things into consideration you kind of
feel sorry for star-lord especially
after he just sort of finally got with
Gamora or at least we saw it on screen
for the first time because we know that
in the first two guardians of the galaxy
movies there wasn't really anything at
the end of guardians of the galaxy -
Gamora kind of mentioned there is this
unspoken thing but nothing has really
happened but then in Avengers infinity
war we see them kiss and we hear them
tell each other that they love each
other
unfortunately that is right before
Thanos takes Gamora and ultimately ends
up sacrificing her for the soul stone
giving everything that has kind of led
up to this moment and then him losing
Gamora it's really understandable that
star-lord reacted the way he did when he
found out that Gamora was killed think
he reacted in a way that's very human
and I think
humanity of the audience the galaxies
what sets him apart from other
superheroes I think goes on to say and
also keep in mind that he's sort of
talking as if he's starlet as well that
if they did it a hundred times he
wouldn't change a thing which is
interesting because if you think about
it Doctor Strange went forward in time
over 14 million times and out of all of
those scenarios there's only one in
which they defeated Danos and in that
scenario star-lord is still punching
Thanos in the face we know this because
right before Doctor Strange
disintegrates he tells Tony that
everything went according to plan
essentially by him telling Tony that
this was the only way he is really
telling us that this scenario was the
only way that we can eventually defeat
Thanos but I would not be surprised that
if in all of those 14 million scenarios
star-lord is punching Thanos in the face
and every single one of them or at least
attempting to maybe somebody jumps in
the way I'm sure they're scenarios that
played out obviously there was over 14
million so I'm sure there's times where
starlight shoots him kicks him head
butts in I'm sure there's times where
dr. strange jumps in the way Tony Stark
jumps in the way just millions of
different scenarios and I bet you in a
vast majority of those he's attacking
Thanos somehow
Chris Pratt obviously does not think it
is star Lords fault that Danno snapped
half of the universe out of existence
but he does have an opinion on the
matter and also I blame fan OHS okay
yeah no he's not good any blame yes
really I'm very sensitive you've had to
deal with alone yes so let's give
Stallard a break guys he has had it
rough recently especially you know since
he died but I'm excited to see how they
bring him back in Avengers 4 because we
know that they're going to be a
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 so they're
going to do with somehow that's it for
this video I hope you all enjoyed it if
you did click that thumbs up button for
me and subscribe to my channel if you'd
like to see other videos like this and
updates on Avengers for Marvel and
everything superhero thank you so much
for watching
woof woof so you know you know I guess
you could have the movie and a half-hour
earlier if you wanted
see my people really like this
[Music]
you